You know I always think about that picture where it looks like two people kissing or like a glass of champagne
Like I'm you know like the flute
I'm so fascinated by perspective like adversity either crumbles you or becomes foundational to your success
You got your perspective
Well I'll also tell you this this is something just at a much higher level you
find yourself and change positions because life is only changed
There is no it stops
like there is only there's only one constant that things are always changing and
you know you you may perceive them as not changing but they're changing things are moving at all times
my grandmother is crying because of your lack of
Subscribing to my youtube channel can't you just subscribe
Hi my name is Matthew Bella I directed the Netflix documentary minimalism
I'm curious for people who are trying to find meaning in life
To live a meaningful life what would you say I think a couple things you know this it's a very heavy question I think
people first of all have to give a lot more thought to the environment and the parents that raised them
there's a lot of answers in there like a lot
so that's interesting to me that's just one heartache I
believe one of the great ways to
mix things up is
What you listen to and who you surround yourself with?
I
would I'm
unbelievably passionate about people finding more optimistic practical friends
and I and I think optimism gets
can get can slide into delusion which is why I say optimistic Oprah chol you know
it's funny as you were talking about middle ism like I didn't
It it's so interesting that you're the first person ever say it to me that I can recall and it feels very real to me
like I don't have outside things
Kind of driving me and that's what leads me to a lot of happiness and so I would say auditing your circle
like if somebody wants to meet a minute to life living a meaningful life leave just get happier I
Think the people that you spend your time with is a big one the amount of people listening right now
who've got a mother who's super pessimistic and cynical but they love their mother and they don't realize that
cutting down their time from seven hours a week of engagement with their mother to two and adding
like going out of their way to seeing the person that's always smiling in the office and
trying to spark up a friendship and become friends with that person and
cutting up that seven hours a week from mom too - - mom maybe 30 minutes with that person and maybe
reallocating the other hours to themselves or other things is a massive deal it's a massive deal
like
there's only offense and defense
there's only the force in the dark side
right and I think that um right now people are a lot of people are choosing
To be driven by fear and negativity
without realizing it and so if you're listening right now my biggest thing is start leaning into a little bit more of
optimism and positivity I think where it overcorrects is when it goes into delusion and that's when you start craving
entitlement and that is the tightrope that I've been
talking about thinking about watching
and it's I
create
entitlement a lot of times because I like positivity and it took me a little while maybe 20 or 30 years 20 years of operating
and managing and parenting and being like okay I think I can see this but I'm not but I'm a product of not I
Kind of fell into customizing all by accident my cousin asked me if I could fix his shoes
Did more research saw that art was being done on shoes and that's how I got to where I'm at today
like the consumerization of like America and like what people deem a success is
Something I've been thinking about a ton like a it's super on my mind
like there was no reason for you to having to go broke again yeah just you bought dumb shit because that's the culture
yeah I was young yes I was seeing people do it and I totally understand I wasn't worried about the next
step of course no
But I feel like everything that. I've gone through today has been very valuable in my success now only because
You've been able to build on top of it
like adversity either crumbles you or becomes foundational to your success
I you know I always think about that picture where it looks like two people kissing or like a glass of champagne
Like I'm you know like the flute. I'm so fascinated by perspective the amount of people who decide in your situation
When you hurt your back that's see see it was just about to get good
but God took it away from me and just give up is a lot I
mean that
and then people who like go into a wheelchair because they're paralyzed and decide that's the platform that they're gonna use
to like change the world
I'm just so fast about perspective
There were literally people today worldstar picked up a clip that I posted about me doing a garage sale flip how much of cars
oh, sorry 25 cars it's perfect
Yes thank you so much
man wish you well take care of sup destroyed their faces
it's at least a honda and literally people are like going in there yeah and people going in there flaming me and saying you're ripping
people off and I'm fascinated by
perspective
like I'm just fascinated by people's ability to deploy cynicism
okay
I'm 17 right now out in LA in turn it for them I know my value
how do I make other people see it beyond the
Monetary gain if there is none you just ask and you don't dwell on somebody not seeing it
It just becomes a matter of time and if you don't feel like
Somebody's paying you or seeing the value you just find the next person to have the conversation with
You know yeah alright you can't force somebody that you want to see something to see something
You either decide to stay the course and give a discount
and however you've defined the discount
Cuz you want to do it for that person like if I want my Tyson to think I'm the coolest
Then I can work for him for four even five years until he does or I
Could be like fuck you Mike Tyson I'm gonna work for Evander Holyfield
got it yeah it was
My name is Joey eco and I live in LA I make music
How you doing okay what's been going on it seems like things are going well?
I'm where you don't make music in English
because it naturally happens that way or thoughtfully you wanted to go about it that way
Got it yeah
Yeah like like if you go into booth or if you like go musical does it like like you think in Spanish
Do we still want to ask you that right away was it's kind of like I think a lot of the reasons some of my
content goes viral is cuz I think in Russian and there's a lot of rumors yeah I was born in Russia
yeah in Belarus specifically and I think in Russian and so a lot of sayings and things I think are
trans I'm translating them from a Russian standpoint to English and
they haven't been said that way in English even though they're things that you know
Like my favorite saying that something my grandma used to say was you can't put your ass on two toilets
which was basically like don't get stretched thin yeah so like when
I like sometimes make content I'll so I could say that and I was like that's insane
But they just had never heard that in that it's all the same shit that like all these sayings in every language are the same
like trying to make the same point but the analogies are different and
So I think a lot of my analogies are unique because I'm not well-read and
because I think in Russian and so what as
I've been listening to your stuff and then like and then just like hearing you talk right now and I'm like
huh I wonder if she
when, she's creative thinks in Spanish and that's why that happens I mean
Opportunity yeah yeah, I get it so I'm basically at this point in my
Everything I've made I've just scrapped scrapped just like I'm my own pocket like yep
Yep work save invest in your career exactly but so I'm just like in that
like we're talking to a couple of labels but like that hasn't happened and we're taking our time with that and I want to put
Some music out exactly you want leverage exactly the longer I wait the more leverage
100% that's well God well it God willing something gets crazy and pops you've got all you got much more leverage I understand
That is the model yeah that's the beauty of tonight
You feel it
yep
and you know what and you know what's funny
like a lot of times we were like I know my worth you're being actually more thoughtful than that you're
putting yourself in a position
to allow the market to establish your worth yeah everybody knows they're worth the amount of people there's millions of people running around
saying I know my worth and never do anything
because the market doesn't give them the leverage to create worth
what I like about what you're doing is you're not sitting in your room
ideologically saying I know my worth you're putting in work to get money to put yourself in a position
You're doing it the right way
No, it's real I mean it no I mean it I mean it like I think I know my worth it's like when people always
Say look I'm not willing to work for free I know my worth and I'm like you you go
Like you have cute you're winning you're building a foundation on humility
you're actually working and I'm sure you know I'm not sure but
I assume you need to have a job that gives you flexibility so you're probably not making a billion dollars a year
Exactly
Yep and so like I just I just wish more youngsters would follow your blueprint
people are just not willing to eat shit and like it's just entitlement
everybody just decided they're the best rapper in the world and they just leave comments on rappers
Instagrams and be like you haven't heard me yet I'm the best cool show me
of course that's like
like it's caught it's called SoundCloud and Spotify like you have distribution yeah if you're so good show me
everyone's talking
Good for you it's exactly right that's the way to do it every single artist in the world should build leverage I
taught myself photography
in 2007 people started hiring me
So much so that by 2008 I was traveling the world is such a pleasure hello we actually met in May of
2017 at the four DS event I have to say thank you because that event changed my life how so you
Inspired me to start something new in my business and a couple months later I launched a brand new product in your business social curator
which is that monthly system to get membership
and we provide
30 lifestyle photos 30 caption templates to help people talk about their business without selling you know and then an action plan in a community
and within 12 months we created a seven-figure revenue stream in the business so somebody took what we learned
started applying it and I just have to say thank you because it's not about the business like you empowered me to be me so
Thank you it's not it's an awesome that makes me I if that's all I get to say to you like it's totally worth it
So we currently have six thousand members and we're on trend to reach 10,000 by the end of 2018 and
so
We have a community and I asked the community hey what would you guys like to see next and the thing that we heard of
the most is that people want to social curator app
Because I can see if they want to remove the friction from taking the resources that we provide for them and pushing it to their
social platforms and
then things get a little bit tricky because when I started asking what features do you find the most valuable in an app if you
Were to create one the number one thing was we want to organize plan and all our posts but we want to use these resources
if I were to create an app that service their
primary demands or requests it would put me squarely in the
organizational planning app space which is a totally different business model than what I currently have
So my question to you is if you were me would you
Create the app or. Would you like
triple down on the investment that the time and the cost to create an app that's a slightly different business model that we currently have
and puts us squarely in a different type of app space
Um my first read is. I'd probably consider to quadruple down on what's already working
and go from 6,000 to 60,000 and
use that leverage of even 6,000 to probably JV with an organizing app
that creates some sort of relationship
I'm I think
that people need to be thoughtful about what they're good at and
Then be even more thoughtful about what doesn't come as natural or what they may not be as interested in I
would say in parrot based on that I would say consider
finding an app partner that already does what you're thinking about building and say to them you call up Charlie and say hey Charlie I'm
6,000 fucking people paying me and
they want this I don't necessarily want to do it
How's your business going you don't know what's out there do you know many apps I'll give you one I would look at the bottom
50 apps in the space
I'll tell you why they've might have they might have 30 you know any app guys and girls are out there that makes 600 apps
and this is one of them that they made and they actually built a really good product but they're focused on the one that popped
and you can like swoop up and take the technology for five thousand bucks
you have to explore I think you should look at the bottom 50 apps I
Have a funny yeah I have a funny feeling think about it right
You might be able to like if you think about it's about you know you you look at top 10 right you go to
They have leverage because there are top 10 for reason you go to number 83 number 83 might be a better app than top 10
the person's just not working it
I'm
unbelievably passionate about people finding more optimistic practical friends I'm fascinated by
perspective like I'm just fascinated by people's ability to deploy
cynicism and so like I just I just wish more youngsters would follow your brain